also i want to give credit where
credit's due a lot of these questions
are from its complicated channel you
guys should go follow him
yeah yeah so a lot of these uh he's very
good at what he does i steal them from
him but yeah would you trust a female
cop to stop a sexual assault what do you
mean by trust
if a woman's getting sexually assaulted
would you trust a female cop to start it
so you're calling the police and they
send a woman do you trust her i mean
i'd assume that the man could overpower
her so
so now
okay
i would trust her to
try to the best of her ability to stop
it because she is a police officer and
that is her job to protect and serve and
that's why she was called to the
situation
[Music]
god may end up getting shot i don't see
how
you know
she just because she's in the uniform
she might be able to overpower him
you know i don't see
um
that happening
you know he probably should shoot the
guy or something but actually literally
stopping it i don't know i don't think
so
[Music]
um i think yeah me answering as a female
i would feel safer even just someone
else being there because i think like
maybe with two of us we would be able to
stop him as opposed to just me on my own
so you would trust
yeah i mean i'd feel better if it was a
man but it is what it is okay
the the female officer is empowered
um has methods that
a bystander wouldn't be allowed to use
she can use weapons she can call her
back up
um
if she does use lethal force she has a
lot of protector whereas a bystander
wouldn't so would i feel more protected
of a woman officer coming up to
stop my sexual assault
no
but
would she as a female officer
feel more enabled to end that sexual
assault i think so
so if i was a woman however i agree with
you 100 percent just having the other
person there makes that assaulter kind
of freak out
would he stop
could that woman stop him i don't know
but maybe she had her weapons maybe
but the bystander no so i think the
female cop
yes could stop it but um females in
general i don't think would be able to i
think i would like um because it comes
down to also skill
and if she has a weapon as well like i
hope she has a gun
but if you ask me
i'm hanging from a cliff
and there's a man and a woman who would
have picked to lift me up it would
obviously be a man when it comes to
power yeah i would trust a man
but because of skill and training
yeah i wouldn't really have a problem
yeah but the thing is
like police officers don't have guns and
stuff so like if it was happening here
wouldn't you just rather i don't even
know what happens here oh yeah oh yeah
uk and police officers don't have guns
definitely a man yeah that's why
it just hit me i was thinking about nypd
is the question pertaining to
a woman being sexually assaulted or if
it was
the individual in general
if a woman's being sexually assaulted i
feel sorry what about if it was a man is
that not relevant to what you're i'm i
mean the the perpetrator is a man in
both scenarios
i mean if he's able to overpower me if
the guy's able to find me i'd assume
he'd be able to also overpower the
female so okay
why are men expected to be protectors if
it is said that women are just as
capable
you know because it's their duty
if you're not my mum my sister my girl
significant other
a friend
i will not protect you like i'm sorry
like i don't know what you've done i
don't know who you've you know
that shows
shows
but what i would say is if i just see
someone on the street arguing with their
boyfriend and he happens to have i'm
sorry i'm walking away yeah i'll call
the police for you i'm walking away
okay so this happened like a year ago
i was
indulged in i'm going through like the
thing
this this guy this tall guy like walks
up on this woman you could see from her
face she was like terrified
didn't know from eve but like
i just walked up to her and i said
you know not looking at the guy i said
um are you ready let's go
you know are you all right
you know and the guy just looked at me
and i could see he was gazing i mean he
just walked away
so
and then when he walked away i just said
oh you're right and i just and she's
like nodding and i just turned away so
i understand what you're saying
you like don't want to get
you don't want to get tangled up in it
but at the same time like the kind of
dude i'm i'd still be walking away like
yo okay but what if what if that was her
boyfriend right and you ended up getting
in the fight with him go to prison and
then she goes back to him afterwards
wouldn't you feel like a [ __ ]
i'm sorry i'm not i'm not putting my
life on the line or even like an extreme
that happens oh no that happens all the
time
it happens so many times when and it's
like why should i put my life on the
line for a situation i don't even know
the ins and outs of yeah i mean
i definitely understand that part
um i have a question what if she's
getting graped
grapes is a bit different okay because
no matter what's happening that's wrong
you yeah you know no matter what's
happening that's always wrong so i would
intervene but if it's just someone
getting a fight i'm calling the police
like okay
what if he was like a massive dude
excuse me this girl
i'd still try to do something
accordingly still but i still try to do
something that's completely different
it's always i think it's always wrong
yeah you know i've done obviously it's
wrong
it comes down to like your safety as
well yeah of course but that's i think
it's a bit different in that situation i
gotta say when when you're seeing it
happen yeah that's that's why
the judgment call comes in a little
different to what like in reality about
what we might places are actually for
this man to protect i think like the
first thing
that's gonna say yeah
that's why i think girls get away with a
lot of stuff too is they know that they
know if they they act a certain way in
public men will come to their rescue
because
you see them in court crying and stuff
because like our default is like oh
protect she's crying she's hurt you know
how
girl doing something to a guy and then
her boyfriend having to bear the
repercussions of her doing that thing to
the guy so yeah you know a woman
starting on the mat and then that man
punching her boyfriend up
i think that's starting to reverse
though now i i've experienced it
personally
um i used to open the door for every
woman
young or old
and uh so many times have i had to say
thank you for them
and i'll say it loudly oh you're welcome
you know and and what i'm walking away
thinking is like you know what that's
the last time i ever opened a door for a
woman seriously
and and i've i i'm ashamed to say that i
saw it because it changed me
in the negative i think that's something
nice to do for everyone i was taught
that that's what you do for a woman i
believe that's wrong i think that's
something you do for everyone
but i see that the chivalry that a lot
of women like to see in guys
is kind of disappearing
i think it should and because we don't
appreciate you know whether it's sure it
shouldn't i think we're in a state where
one group of us wants it the other group
of us wants to do it but doesn't see the
point and actually gets a lot of crap
you know what i've noticed so we're just
kind of like at